if you had to be stuck in a room with
just one person and it wasn't your wife
or kid wasn't my wife a kid do my wife
and kids exist
oh that's an important question because
I know where you're going because I want
to know is sex on the table
wait a minute if I'm in a room wait a
minute I just changed I just changed my
personal attack you know what I'm saying
I just I was like thinking survival and
I'm like wait wait wait wait there's
another question no it's anything is
like let's
it's humanity and it's fine it's um no
so let's yeah let's say they don't let's
say none of our families exist you just
stuck in a room and you have to choose
someone
all right well okay if sex isn't on the
table I'm gonna pick my best friend
Philip Grant who I've known since I was
five years old
that's awesome yeah since kindergarten
help you out like you know there's
survivalists he is okay he's like I'm
not a super handy guy okay but he is
like DIY all day long so he can fix
stuff okay so he's a good cook too you'd
pick him and he'd pick someone else no
because you don't entertain him
that's amazing I'm good for a chuckle
yeah so that would be him if it was if
sex was on the table I'd pick somebody
else yeah me too
[Applause]
um
experience it will definitely that's not
on the table I honestly think I'm I'm
gonna pick my sister because this is why
we didn't actually grow up together oh
really yeah we did it dysfunctional
American family
um but um anyway but we're so similar
and I think I'd pick her just because I
think we're able to be very honest with
each other yes like look I need a minute
yeah without you in it right
you know what I'm saying but also
she's really we can both build fire we
can both do we're like survivalist
people really were you girl scouts yes I
was a girl
yes I I love all of that I have every
book if you've ever came in my house
you'd probably be like she might have a
problem no but like I think it's fun
like I love biosity I'm I'm totally into
this kind of concept for a movie show
everything like basically you tell me if
it happens I'm coming to your house I
tell all my friends because none of
those
prepared yeah
I'm like yeah I'm like everybody is
gonna come to my house so I gotta have
enough for everybody yeah um but yeah no
I'm that person and you'd want to be
stuck in a room because I'm I'm pretty
handy okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]